a group of Ivy League students is asking
a federal court to force fraternities to
accept women as members three women are
suing Yale University and nine of its
fraternities they accuse them of
allowing dangerous environments in which
sexual misconduct thrived meg Oliver
asked the women why they wanted to join
the fraternities in an interview you'll
see first on CBS this morning she's near
Yale's campus and New Haven Connecticut
may good morning good morning the three
women we spoke with are hoping their
lawsuit leads to change
they say fraternities here dominate a
limited social scene around campus one
that needs to be wiped clean of sexual
harassment and gender discrimination
raise your hand if you've ever been
sexually assaulted at a fraternity party
all of you Anna McNeill le singer and
Wray Walker say they've had enough of
inappropriate behavior by men at Yale
fraternity parties someone came up from
behind me and started grinding on me and
then actually pulled up my skirt I was
groped from behind a lot of people were
grinding against me from behind I
couldn't see them in a lawsuit they
allege female undergraduates risk sexual
harassment and assault by attending
fraternity events they say men deny
female students admission based on their
appearance verbally harassed them grind
against them grab them and grope them
why do you want to be part of a culture
that you're alleging promotes sexual
misconduct fraternity party wasn't any
of our first choice but it was kind of
the only choice for the first couple of
months at school it speaks to the way
that fraternities dominate the social
culture at Yale those are places that
are open late at night and those are
spaces that some of our friends are
hosting parties in you know return Dee's
offer a vast network of privileges to
their members they offer connections
they offer help networking some people
might argue sororities do the same thing
sororities don't tend to have nearly the
same connections as fraternities
fraternities often have people I think
in higher positions of power and
certainly on campus they often they
occupy a much higher social space their
lawsuit against Yale in 9th eternities
argues separate but equal Greek life
reinforces gender norm
stereotypes and prejudices they're
seeking class-action status asking the
court to award damages and to order
policy changes including fully
integrating women at Yale's fraternities
the case is enormous ly complicated CBS
News legal analyst Rickey Clements says
she's confused by what she sees as the
lawsuits contradictory goals if I am
someone who goes into a party at the
only place available for me to socialize
which is a fraternity and I'm being
groped and sexually assaulted and in an
environment that I think is unsafe why
do I want to join the fraternity why
don't I want the fraternity ban I think
I speak for all of us when I say that
banning fraternities isn't counter to
our objectives we're adopting the kind
of gender integration model because we
think it's one that's you know more
feasible that's worked similarly in
other contexts in the past the women are
part of a group which has repeatedly
filed complaints asking Yale to regulate
fraternities David Tracy is their lawyer
yells response has been deliberately
indifferent Yale has known about the
problem of fraternity related
discrimination and sexual misconduct for
at least a decade pledges of one
fraternity allegedly posed for a photo
outside the Yale Women's Center with a
sign reading we love Yale [ __ ] another
fraternity was banned after pledges
reportedly paraded around chanting no
means yes a third fraternity faced
allegations of turning away women of
color because they wanted white girls
only what's the optimal outcome of this
lawsuit I think to put it simply we just
want a paradigm shift right now students
are forced to make a choice between
having a social life and not feeling
safe at parties or feeling safe but
barely being able to go out at all we
want Yale to take decisive action to
make that change so people no longer are
forced to make that choice in a
statement Yale told us they have no
comment on this lawsuit but that all
students are subject to discipline for
sexual misconduct now the lawyer
representing all of the fraternities
told us the claims in this lawsuit are
base
and unfounded and they look forward to
vigorously defending this action in
court the case focuses on fraternities
here at Yale but no doubt other schools
will be watching Gail
I'll say it started an interesting
conversation Thank You Meg